The War in Ukraine has been raging for ten
months now.
In the first days of the war, Russia made
rapid advances on three axes, threatening
to conquer Ukraine’s East, South and Center.
Instead, the Russian army suffered a massive
defeat around Kyiv, then around Kharkiv, then
in the South-West, around Kherson.
Russians are now down to controlling Crimea,
parts of the East, and a strip of land connecting
the two.
They are on the defensive almost everywhere,
and have opted to conduct massive terror bombardments
of Ukrainian civilian infrastructure with
ballistic missiles.
All in all, Russians seem to have become stuck,
with no victory in sight.
Or have they?
Lately there has been more and more talk of
a second Russian offensive against Kyiv, and
Ukrainians seem to be struggling somewhat
with the defense of Bakhmut, a strategically
important city in the East.
As winter approaches, what can we expect on
the short, mid and long term?
Will there be a second Battle of Kyiv?
Let’s take a look.
The most important question to answer first
and foremost, is “What are current Russian
war goals in Ukraine?”
And the answer is: the exact same as before:
the conquering of Ukraine.
Now you might think that’s absolutely ludicrous.
After all those defeats and humiliations,
a hundred thousand casualties and currently
8480 visually confirmed heavy equipment losses,
does Putin still seriously intend on conquering
Ukraine?
Yes.
That still remains the political goal of this
war for Russia.
And the Russian leadership plans to achieve
this via, for example, bombing Ukrainian civilian
infrastructure with ballistic missiles --a
war crime--, to deprive Ukrainians of heat
and energy during winter, thus degrade the
morale of both the population and the troops.
However, this plan doesn’t seem to be working.
Though they have done significant damage to
Ukrainian energy facilities, most Russian
ballistic missiles are still getting shot
down.
From their latest, massive barrage of 76 missiles,
60 were shot down by Ukrainian air defense,
with some failing on their own before even
reaching Ukraine.
Meanwhile, partner countries keep supplying
electric equipment and generators to help
keep the Ukrainian grid operational.
And so far they’ve been successful.
In addition, at the time of making this video
it seems more and more likely that the US
will deliver its advanced Patriot air defense
systems to Ukraine, which would dull the edge
of Russian terror bombings even further.
But ballistic missiles aimed at civilians
is not the only way Putin is trying to get
his way.
As of the second half of December, 2022, rumors
are circulating about a new Russian offensive
against Kyiv.
The commander of the Ukrainian military, General
Zaluzhnyi, was quoted saying he has “no
doubt they will have another go at Kyiv.”
The Institute for the Study of War assesses
such offensive to be “extraordinarily unlikely
to succeed”.
However, so far such minor details haven’t
stopped Russians from trying.
If Russians indeed decide to attack, they
would need to drag Belarus into the conflict,
which Putin seems to be attempting currently.
In a very rare personal visit to Belarus,
Putin will no doubt try to pressure Lukashenko
into joining the invasion.
However, for Lukashenko this is extremely
dangerous.
If the Belarussian armed forced get chewed
up inside Ukraine, and there is a very good
chance they would, that would weaken Lukashenko’s
rule directly, since the only thing keeping
him in power is brute force at this point.
The Belarussian military is in no shape for
an invasion.
They have around fifty thousand military personnel,
with obsolete equipment.
And they cannot throw everything at Ukraine
either, because then who will man the borders,
who will keep the order in case people try
to overthrow Lukashenko again, and so on.
And it’s not like Ukrainians would be caught
by surprise.
Ever since beating the Russians out of the
north, they’ve established proper defenses
along the Belarussian border.
If the fresh and somewhat prepared Russian
military couldn’t break the original defenses
that time, a worn-down Russian military with
rag-tag Belorussian support certainly won’t
break the improved defenses this time.
Now let’s talk about the Ukrainian objectives.
The long-term goal is of course the same:
remove Russian troops from the entire territory
of Ukraine.
The short-term goal is to keep the Russians
at bay in the East, and gain advantageous
positions everywhere via incremental progress.
The mid-term goals are far more interesting
however.
Ever since the Ukrainian victory and Russian
withdrawal in Kherson, there has not been
any major breakthroughs along the frontlines.
That was due to the Ukrainian mud season,
which makes large-scale maneuvers practically
impossible.
However, that certain cold season is coming.
In a few weeks the ground will freeze solid,
enabling maneuvers once again.
And this is when I believe Ukraine will start
another large-scale offensive.
But where?
In the South, the two armies are separated
by the massive Dnipro river.
Trying to attack through it would be incredibly
difficult, and Ukrainians would run into prepared
Russian defensive lines on the other side.
In the East, Ukrainians are holding the line
and grinding down frustrated Russian assaults,
this is the Bakhmut area, and are making incremental
advances towards Kreminna and Svatove, in
order to cut a major supply line for Russian
troops in the area.
The frontlines are largely static there.
I personally doubt we’ll be seeing any major
offensives in that area in the near future,
but I could be wrong of course.
This leaves us with the Southeast.
A large, flat, open area, north of which the
Ukrainian military has been massing for months,
not coincidentally.
This is the most likely area of a large-scale
Ukrainian offensive, which I believe we’ll
be seeing in the coming months.
The main objective of the Winter Offensive
would be to take Tokmak and Melitopol, both
being major supply hubs, thus cutting Russian
forces in half.
Geographically speaking.
IF Ukrainians manage to pull it off, I’m
fairly certain that would be the beginning
of the end for the Russian invasion.
And why is that?
Currently Russian troops south of Kherson
and in Crimea can be supplied via two routes.
One through Melitopol, and the other through
Kerch.
However, the Kerch bridge has been damaged,
and is out of commission for heavy military
echelons for at least half a year or so.
Russians therefore have to resort to ferrying
supplies to Crimea, which is slow, ineffective,
and vulnerable.
If the Melitopol supply route would be cut,
the Kerch ferry would be struggling to supply
both the Russian invasion force AND the civilian
population of Crimea.
At that point, Russia would find itself in
a situation like Kherson, only on a larger
scale.
Where they have a whole lot of troops dug
in, connected by a crippled supply line, slowly
being ground down by Ukrainian strikes and
assaults.
But this I believe is on the farther end of
the Ukrainian midterm goals.
So where does all this put Russian mobilization
efforts?
Can Russia come out with a massive wave of
fresh troops to overwhelm Ukrainian defenders,
and achieve their war goals?
No.
The Soviet mobilization infrastructure is
largely gone.
What remains cannot cope with the sheer number
of new recruits.
Beyond huge issues with training, including
the lack thereof, equipping those soldiers
is also either sub-par, or doesn’t happen.
Many Russian mobilized have to buy their own
gear before heading into the combat zone.
Such recruits can keep Ukrainian defenders
busy, but aren’t good for much else, such
as complex combined arms maneuvers.
I expect the lack of proper equipment will
become an especially severe problem during
the cold.
Case in point, it’s not even the dead of
winter yet, but we’ve already seen Russian
troops affected by hypothermia due to lack
of winter gear.
Soldiers also need to be fed more during the
cold, as the body burns more calories to keep
warm.
With the current degraded, inefficient Russian
supply lines we’ll likely see food shortages
among Russian troops, further decreasing their
combat capabilities.
If a well-supplied Ukrainian military attacks
then, things could get very ugly very fast
for the Russians.
To sum up, winter is bound to be pretty hot
in Ukraine.
The initiative remains firmly with Ukrainians,
and Putin or his general, Surovikin likely
won’t be able to change that, especially
with an ill-fated second assault on Kyiv.
And if Ukrainians manage to take Melitopol
in the South and reach the sea, it would be
a game changer for this whole conflict, and
would mark the beginning of the end for the Russians.